so I've come here today because you
promised me cash but I don't see any
money I thought you were paying me for
these things but now we're not talking
about that sort of cash we're actually
we're looking for the cash that is built
into our CPUs and are used in computers
to try and make things run faster now we
talked about how the CPU talks to memory
and we spent some time looking at how we
can build memory chips out of discrete
logic circuits why do you want to build
all the memory in your computer system
like that there are other ways you can
build them to create sims as you're
using in their sort of late 80s early
90s this one's about 256 kilobytes but
you can get dims that are as big as 16
gig these days now if you remember back
to what Steve Furber was saying about
when you built the BBC micro he was
talking about how when they built it
they used RAM chips that ran at twice
the speed of the CPU so got a dram chips
here and they're connected directly more
or less to the CPU here the memory ran
at four megahertz and the CPU ran at two
megahertz and so the CPU could make its
request and the RAM would return it very
quickly and while the CPU was still
pressing that values the video circuits
could grab the data from memory to form
the displays it was able to multiplex or
- and not slow the CPU down and like
some of the systems now as time went on
the CPUs got much faster so by the end
of the 80s you could get CPUs like this
which ran at eight megahertz and then 16
megahertz 32 megahertz and so on and now
at 3 gigahertz CPU is very easy to get
hold up unfortunately the RAM didn't
increase its speed at the same rate
these days of RAM runs several orders of
magnitude slower than what the CPU runs
at so this leaves us with a problem even
if the clock speed of the CPU increased
it would still have to wait for the
memory so that it wouldn't actually
appear to get any faster so actually it
is possible to build memory that will
work at the speed that the CPU executes
sack but the problem is it takes more
space on the silicon to store each bit
of information and so therefore it cost
a lot more to produce the memory
compared to the dims the DRAM that we
use today so the way we get around this
is we split the memory up into two times
we have our main memory which we build
out of dynamic Ram but we also have a
second type of memory which is actually
often built into the CPU as well now
this is much
smaller but it's built out of much
faster memory and this is referred to as
the cash now the cash is perhaps a an
old-fashioned English word but it
basically just means a small place where
we can store things so you might use it
to store your hidden treasure if you're
a pirate or to store your food for
winter
another example where you might have
come across a cache is with your web
browser so the cache on the web browser
is used to get around because it takes a
relatively long time to fetch you a
piece of information over the internet
compared to accessing something on your
local machine so what happens is when
you go and fetch a page from the
Internet the browser will go and get the
HTML page it will get the CSS files the
images and so on and it stores or caches
a copy onto your local disk that you can
then refer to if it needs to get it
again and the idea is that we can get
the data from the local copy a lot
quicker than it could if you had to go
and fetch it from the web server
somewhere else in the world and it's the
same approach that is used by the CPU
the CPUs got the same problem it can
talk to its cache on the CPU very very
quickly
but talking to main memory compared to
talking to the cache is a relatively
long time so what happens every time it
requests a bit of data it caches a copy
locally in the cache built on to the CPU
so that when it needs to fetch it again
in the near future you can access it
from its local copy a lot faster there's
some other tricks that it can do as well
because the CPU can say well actually if
I fetch this instruction there's a very
good chance that I'm going to execute
the next instruction and the one after
that at the same time and so what it can
do is rather than just getting one word
of memory at a time it'll say well okay
get me the next 128 bytes of memory and
it'll read what we call a cache line one
single lot of 128 bytes from memory into
the CPU in one go the idea being that it
takes less time to read 128 bytes in one
go than just to read each 128 bytes
individually that's down to the way
memory actually store things so we
talked about in the previous video how
we would have an address a binary number
that represents each different bit in
the RAM chips but actually rather than
storing it as one big list of bits it
actually stores it as a grid the address
you give it from the CPU gets split up
to reference
particular row and a column of that grid
to get the particular bit its interested
in now the way the RAM chips have worked
once you've selected a specific row you
can then access each of the columns in
that relatively quickly compared to
changing to a different row so if we
want to get 128 bytes if they're all in
the same row of memory then we can
access them very quickly and so copy
them into the CPUs cache much quicker
than if we were having to select
different rows at a time so how big does
the cache on your CPU need to be well
actually it turns out that you only need
a relatively small amount of cash to
make a significant difference because I
programs often sitting in loops
executing the same set of instructions
again and again and again so if you've
got enough to store that loop then they
can be cached and it'll work fine all
the programs accessing the same block of
data and manipulating that in different
ways and so if that will fit into the
cache things work relatively fine so we
don't need that much you often use
separate caches for the instructions and
for the data so that you don't remove
the instruction that you're interested
in to put a copy of the data that you're
going to process in there you can think
about it that you might have a field
full of turnips and so you'd have to go
and dig them up but you might also have
a cupboard with your turnips in in the
kitchen so you can make yours do that
night without having to go out into the
field and if you're out working
somewhere else you may even have a
turnip in your backpack to eat on the
way out second level turnip cut yeah so
for example let's say we say that dead
people don't consume it then you have a
an AI which will never attempt CPR
this person's died they go and forget
about it done